all right i want to take some time and
talk about gas prices gas prices are
high there's no denying it but the level
of hyperbole and drama and the sky is
falling crazy statements from right-wing
media are starting to really get to be a
little bit too much let me give you just
an absurd example of this fox news has
an anchor named sandra smith
she says that gas prices were keeping
her up at night guys listen i understand
being concerned about inflation i
understand being concerned about the
cost of shipping things that go by truck
because of gas prices this is a real
issue and i've been taking it seriously
we're supposed to believe sandra smith
was up at night she couldn't sleep
because of gas prices listen to this as
you said pollen kept you up last night
you know it kept me up last night can we
even can we even
tap into the spr
in the quantity the capacity
that we're talking about is it possible
a million barrels a day so i reached out
to pipeline workers i reached out to
those in the industry as many as i could
we have never historically tapped that
amount is it possible the answer i'm
being given is no okay so first of all i
don't believe this was keeping her up at
night and if it were it'd be a little
bit weird number two
now the concern is oh we're now we are
tapping the strategic petroleum reserve
that's not good but before the issue was
why isn't joe biden tapping into the sbr
so i'm gonna break this down for you
piece by piece first a really quick word
from our sponsor morning brew if you're
like me and i know uh many of you are in
different ways you probably spend some
of your day kind of mindlessly scrolling
through twitter
or reddit and kind of coming across news
articles but not really taking in
what's going on in the world today
morning brew lets you soak up the entire
day's news
in a focused way that takes about five
minutes a day it's a way better use of
your time morning brew is a free daily
newsletter it's seven days a week in
about five minutes morning brew gets me
caught up on politics business finance
tech just what's going on in the world
in a much more focused and efficient way
much better use of my time they take all
the day's news stories and boil them
down into
just the most important points so you'll
be informed about what's taking place
maybe you like watching the david pakman
show because i take stories
hopefully break them down and give you
the important takeaways and something to
think about that's exactly what morning
brew does but morning brew will keep you
in the loop on more than just politics
like i said when you have a few minutes
of downtime on your phone
don't get bogged down in either clicking
around or one long news article you're
never actually going to finish that's
where morning brew is perfect you get a
well-crafted
series of bite-size articles and you get
through them quickly and you're informed
subscribe to morningbrew right now using
the link below alright so let's take
this seriously gas prices are high
it's not joe biden's fault as i've said
before and when gas prices were higher
lower under obama bush trump presidents
have very little impact over gas prices
as i've said presidents can basically do
three things one they can go to war with
a country where we get oil that'll make
gas prices go up they can argue for a
gas tax break which will make gas prices
go down
and they can release some oil from the
strategic petroleum reserve which will
impact gas prices somewhere in the range
of 5 to 15 cents per gallon now the
first question is
how high are gas prices really the first
step is many people will say well let's
just look at the nominal price of gas if
it's four dollars a gallon now
and it's never been higher than 399 in
the past then gas prices are higher now
but that doesn't take into account
inflation but the problem is
inflation-adjusted gas prices alone
aren't actually that great of a measure
at determining how gas prices are in
reality today so another measure that
can be looked at is
if we account for wages how many minutes
of work are required to purchase a
gallon of gas that's an interesting
metric and if you look at that gas
prices right now
are nowhere near as high as they were in
2008 in 2011 in 2012 2013 2014 they are
getting there they may get there and
i'll i will tell you if that happens but
if we really want to take a more
systemic look at what sort of cost gas
prices represent
there are many times in the past where
the average worker needed to work longer
to buy one gallon of gas
another metric that's interesting is
what is the real price of gas per mile
driven why would we look at that well
even as gas prices go up and down
vehicles have become more efficient over
time and so you might have a higher
nominal gas price
it may be higher or similar in inflation
adjusted terms it may relate to how much
work do you need to do in that you need
to work 10 minutes to afford a gallon of
gas versus 8 but also because cars on
average are more expensive what is the
real cost per mile driven because if you
have a 10 mile commute
and gas it costs more but you need less
of it to make the 10 hour drive
that's also an important metric and if
you look at that as well because
vehicles are significantly more
efficient now
the real price of gas per mile driven
is dramatically lower than it was in the
80s and it is also lower than it was
around 2008 2011 2012 2013.
does this mean we shouldn't care about
high gas prices of course we should of
course we should and i have never hidden
from you what the price of gas is i've
also been consistent that presidents
have very little impact on the price of
gas this gets us to the strategic
petroleum reserve uh joe biden will
start releasing one million barrels of
oil per day
from the reserves
to help cut gas prices this is something
many republicans were demanding now
they're worried we don't have the oil
for it they are bad faith actors but the
most important thing about this is like
i've told you many times before
the estimate
is as a result of this tapping of the
strategic petroleum reserve
gas prices would drop between 5 and 15
cents per gallon this is a global issue
we knew
that's all that would happen
based on opening up the strategic
petroleum reserve and that is exactly
what economists are now telling us